bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 su en
direct jusqu'à 19h nous allons faire le
point comme chaque soir sur l'actualité
du département aujourd'hui nous
parlerons notamment politique avec
Jean-Michel Fourgous le maire UMP
d'élencour l'ancien député de la 11e
circonscription des ivelines battu en
juin dernier par Benoît amont nous
l'entendrons sur les premières en mesure
du gouvernement socialiste et puis nous
verrons aussi comment peut se
reconstruire l'opposition ce sera dans
une vingtaine de minutes le 78 de ce 13
septembre également avec Anthony r
bonsoir Anthony nous allons recevoir
deux athlètes sur ce plateau qui
reviennent tout juste de Londres oui
tout à fait nous accueillons avec grand
plaisir Nathalie Bizet vous avez terminé
7e dans l'épreuve de dressage vous êtes
cavalière malvoyante et vous êtes
licencié à beauvet dansloise mais
résidente à plaisir c'est ça bonsoir et
bonsoir à Florence Sirot euh joueuse de
tennis de table tétraplégique discipline
ou la France dans l'épreuve par équipe a
échoué au quart au stade des quarts de
finale face à la redoutable Chine euh
vous êtes inscrit à hlencour bonsoir
bonsoir et nous vous entendrons dans
quelques instants nous parler un petit
peu de cette cérémonie de clôture vous y
étiez on en verra les images vous nous
direz comment ça s'est passé vous nous
direz aussi comment ça s'est passé
pendant le retour vous n disiez avant de
commencer l'émission que vous avez fait
la fête dans l'urostar vous allez nous
dire tout ça tout à l'heure on va tout
savoir auparavant voici les titres de
l'actualité locale du jour comment
traiter les incivilités dans les
transports la SNCF met en place une
initiative originale une troupe de
comédiens est invité à jouer des scettes
réalistes les journées du patrimoine
c'est ce weekend la compagnie Bul de zin
propose une visite humoristique de
l'agglomération cinquantinoise vous
verrez ce soir comment se prépare cette
compagnie originaire de Nantes
savez-vous que le département des
ivelines est producteur de champignons
de Paris il n'existe que trois
champignonnières d'ailleurs comme ici à
Montesson rencontre ce soir avec ce que
l'on appelle les jardiniers de la nuit
et puis le premier festival coup d'État
de morpa il s'est déroulé lui le weekend
dernier en tête d'affiche Hubert Félix
Tiffen nous y avons croisé de notre côté
jeunny Montreuil un pur rockur interview
dans moins de 20 minutes la SNCF a donc
décidé de lutter contre les fraudes avec
des comédiens des cetes sont donc
dorénavant joué dans les trains
franciliens l'objectif est de permettre
à la SNCF d'économiser plusieurs
millions d'euros par
an qu'est-ce que tu parles de voler ah
non je dis que vous fouillez bien
partout pour voir si je vous ai volé
c'est ce que je veux faire TR mais que
la peste soit de l'avarice et des
avaricieux alors nous avons décidé de
lancer sur les lignes nuU une semaine de
sensibilisation au bien voyager ensemble
au respect des règles de civisme et de
civilité dans nos trains et dans nos
dans nos gares donc on a voulu abord
cette thématique là sur un angle un
petit peu décalé en surprenant les nos
clients avec l'intervention d'une troupe
de comédiens le principe c'est vraiment
de jouer dans les trains de jouer un
théâtre populaire un peu dans le
principe de Molière on joue du théâtre
classique de jouer pour tout le monde
puis on a vraiment un très bon accueil
c'est cette semaine très bien reçu
quiilt des vils et des
lades qui est-ce que tu entends par là
mais de quoi vous mettez-vous en
je me mets en peine de ce qu'il
faut on a eu beaucoup de sourire on a eu
beaucoup d'applaudissements on a eu des
gens un petit peu surpris et agacés je
je je le je je le reconnais on peut pas
plaire à tout le monde mais en tout cas
on a eu de l'impact en 2011 pas moins de
2400 infractions ont été commises sur
ces deux lignes entraînant 13000 minutes
de retard sur l'ensemble du Réau
Transilien le coût des fraudes et des
incivilités est évalué à plus de 5
millions d'euros la compagnie des rails
à Séville une dernière fois ce jeudi
soir en garde
trappe quel bilan pour la délégation
française au Jeux Paralympiques de
Londres c'est ce que nous allons savoir
ce soir avec vous Anthony avec donc nos
invités deux femmes qui étaient engagées
lors des Jeux paralympiques Florence
gociio Siro pongiste et Nathalie Bizet
cavalière vous nous les avez présenté
tout à l'heure avant de se concentrer
justement sur leurs résultats sur les
résultats des ivelinois des ivelinoises
déjà quel bilan pour les Français bah
clment c'est un bilan plutôt mitigé
qu'on qu'on qu'on dresse après ces Jeux
Paralympiques de Londres le comité
Comité paralympique français avait
donneré un objectif de top 10 au
classement des médailles vous savez que
le classement des médailles pour les
Joos se fait seulement avec les titres
or nous navons récolté que H
marseillaises pendant ces pendant ces
jeux paralmpi que les médailles d'or
c'est ça qui en fait VO exactement et au
lieu de l'objectif de 16 titres donc
deux fois moins donc c'est quand même un
un bilan mifig miaisin au-delà de ça on
a quand même ramené 45 médailles dont 19
d'argent et et 18 de bronze voilà alors
du côté des yvelinois des ivelinoises
est-ce que la délégation yvelinoise s'en
est bien sortie et bien oui plutôt on
avait pas énormément de de de sportifs
représentant le le département tout de
même en tennis fauteuil Nicolas per et
et Frédéric catanéo licenciés au
Saint-Quentin tennis en sport ont obtenu
une très très belle médaille d'argent en
double ainsi que nantena Kaita licencié
aussi à Saint-Quentin mais à l'Entente
Athlétique qui a décroché une très belle
médaille de bronze sur le 100 m on
revoit d'ailleurs on va voir justement
sa finale où elle était au couloir 8 au
couloir 8 et donc elle a décrocher cette
médaille de bronze sur 100 m et deux
athlètes sont donc avec nous sur le
plateau oui tout à fait on a un énorme
plaisir à recevoir Florence Florence
Sirot et Nathalie Bizet donc Nathalie
biset vous étiez dans l'épreuve de
dressage en tant que cavalier malvoyante
et Florence Sirot joueuse de tennis de
tétraplégique alors première question
qui me vient un petit peu à l'idée c'est
euh comment vous avez ressenti le bah
l'expérience londonienne on sait que
c'est un peu une une une épreuve assez
particulière surtout par rapport à Pékin
où le la foule était beaucoup plus
présente dans les
stades alors àondre ça a été des jeux
bah magnifiques exceptionnels au niveau
bah au niveau sportif et puis surtout au
niveau du public aussi même si à Pékin
le tennis de table est une discipline FA
donc il y avait déjà il y a 4 ans dans
le gymnase beaucoup beaucoup de monde
mais là les Londoniens en tout cas les
Britanniques ont été aussi présents dans
le gymnase du tennis de table mais je je
sais aussi sur toutes les autres
discipline et justement Nathalie biset
concernant l'équitation on sait que
l'équitation est un domaine très très
important en Grande-Bretagne c'est
pareil les stades étaient pleins les
stades étaient pleins il y avait une
ferveur populaire qu'on a jamais R
rencontré jusqu'à présent alors les
Britanniques sont très Ferrus
d'équitation ils sont très Ferrus de
handicap il faut savoir que l'équipe
paradressage anglaise c'est la meilleure
du monde depuis très longtemps il il il
récolte toutes les médailles possibles
et imaginables essentiellement les
jaunes et donc forcément ça ça ça induit
forcément de la ferveur chez les chez
les spectateurs et et passionnés
d'équitation ce qui a fait que le stade
était plein et qui avait une ambiance
que j'ai jamais rencontré avant les
stades étaient pleins beaucoup dans
engouement sur place autour des des Jeux
paralympiques même si on pourrait on l'a
déjà fait parler sur ce plateau de la
médiatisation des jeux en France c'était
un petit peu plus difficile en tout cas
vous ne ramenez pas de médaille
malheureusement quelle analyse de vos
parcours respectifs est-ce qu'il y a une
déception tout de même est-ce que vous
êtes déçu natal biser euh alors un petit
peu déçu dans le sens où je savais que
je n'étais pas médaillable pour pas mal
de raisons le le top 3 était impossible
à ACC à obtenir pour moi par contre ma
place dans la hiérarchie mondiale est
autour de la 5e ou 6e place donc un
petit peu déçu parce qu'au bout du
compte je suis un petit peu en de
ça mais par contre j'ai rien je me suis
éclaté j'ai pas fait j'ai pas commis de
faute sur mes épreuves la jument a été
merveilleuse le site était fantastique
et du coup oui j'ai un petit peu de
déception quant au résultat mais par
contre c'était des jeux absolument
fantastiques et vous florenceot
justement donc moi j'étais plutôt
outsider donc je savais que j'allais
forcément rencontrer une tête de série
en étant 2è de de ligne dans ma pooule
donc c vous vous avez participé à la
compétition en simple et et par équipe
il faut le savoir par équ donc là je je
parle plutôt en individuel euh donc je
savais que j'avais j'allais rencontrer
une tête de série soit la Chinoise soit
l'italienne soit la Russe j'ai eu
l'italienne la deuxème mondiale
donc je sors pas de poule mais bon j'ai
gagné mon premier match perdu mon
deuxème match sur sur la deuxème
mondiale à la belle c'est la première
fois que je l'accroche aussi bien euh
donc pas de regret au final donc non pas
de regret même si j'ai failli faire
l'exploit il ne s'est pas produit ça
aurait été vraiment une belle et grande
surprise pour tout le monde et pour moi
aussi vous vous étiez beaucoup préparé
on a vu pendant que vous parliez il a
quelques instants quelques images de de
préparation il y a quelques années on
vous avait suivi là vous vous étiez
beaucoup préparé pour ces olympiades euh
oui oui je
importanten qu quotidien alors moi je
sais que je ne m'entraîne pas au
quotidien du fait handicap parce que
l'expérience montre que si je m'entraîne
au quotidien ça va me
desservir la fatigue sera trop
importante donc il faut avec
l'expérience pouvoir justement gérer
cette cet
investissement sportif voilà donc non
pas déçu plutôt plutôt contente je
rentre pas je rentre sans sans regret
contrairement à Pékin donc ça c'est
plutôt positif et puis ça me donne
l'envie de continuer et je sais que je
vais bientôt la battre l'italienne et
plus plus largement au sein de la la
délégation tricolore quelle était
l'ambiance après cette après cette
olympiade plutôt morose on était un
petit peu amer parce que il y avait un
manque de titre
entre nous pas forcément amer parce que
c'est déjà j'allais dire extraordinaire
de participer au jeu alors chacun a des
attentes différentes mais euh la
cérémonie de clôture c'est toujours la
fête dans une ambiance
chaleureuse internationale et puis on
était content que que ça se termine dans
le sens où voilà c'est plutôt festif et
c'est un cycle c'était V 5e olympiade
c'est bien ça également pour vous
Nathalie bisé toutes les deux vous
connaissez déjà justement au sein de la
délégation est-ce qu'on fait la fête au
sein de la délégation est-ce qu'il y a
des liens qui se créent d'une discipline
à une autre euh c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
pendant qu'on est sur nos compétitions
est compé on pas trop le temp côyer les
autes ça je pense que c'estable c'est
valable pour nous cavali parce que les
sites où on s'entraîne monte à cheval
sont en général excentrés par rapport au
village mais je pense que c'est un petit
peu valable pour tout le monde parce que
avant les compétitions et pendant les
compétitions tout toutes les disciplines
nécessit un peu qu'on soit dans sa bulle
donc c'est après éventuellement qu'on
arrive à se côtoyer et pour ça il faut
que le calendrier nous permett d'avoir
quelques jours avant la fin pour pouvoir
se côtoyer donc on a enin moi j'ai
côtoyé il a plein de gens euh maintenant
vous avez fait la fête est-ce que c'est
une grande fête justement parce qu'on on
parle sur pour les athlètes valides
justement que il s'amuse aussi hein
là-bas sur place une fois que les
épreuves sont passées c'est aussi
l'occasion de décompresser là-bas au
jeux parallympiqu c'est pareil pareil
oui oui c'est pareil on s on s'est bien
amusé et puis et puis on a il y a des
choses qui ont été organisées pour nous
moi je sais que j'ai fait partie des
gens qui ont rencontré le président de
la République j'ai fait partie des gens
qui sont aller à l'ambassade de France
on nous a organisé une visite à la Tour
de Londres où on a vu les joyaux de la
reine h et ça c'est quand même assez
privilégié et puis a cette cérémonie de
clôture les imes son passer et puis on a
passé des soirées à bien rigoler à bien
boire des coups et et voilà voilà les
alèes les athlètes des Jeux
paralympiques sont comme les athlètes
des jeux valides c'est pareil il se
passe la même chose Floren vous parlez
justement de l'entraînement et de
l'investissement je voulais savoir
Nathalie Bizet comment vous faites pour
vous entraîner avec votre jument en tant
que malvoyante alors moi je monte à
cheval tous les jours enfin je monte à
cheval 6 jours sur 7 puisqu'elle a droit
un jour de repos elle est en pension
dans une écurie de dressage à côté de
Rambouillet chez Christophe sa au Harad
Saint-Robert et en fait je travaille
avec lui à chaque fois que j'y vais et
je vais monter tous les jours à la
sortie de enfin après le boulot et vous
travaillez comment c'est c'est au bruit
c'est du Galot du trop je ne sais pas
alors on travaille enfin on travaille
aux trois allures puisque le dressage
c'est une discipline qui se fait en
l'occurrence dans ma catégorie aux trois
allures avec aussi des déplacements de
côté et des des figures bien bien
précises euh on est dans un rectangle
qui fait 60 m par 20 dans ce rectangle
il y a des lettres ces lettres sont
toujours les mêmes et elles sont
toujours placées au même endroit et moi
la seule aide dont j'ai besoin c'est que
quelqu'un de l'extérieur me dise la
lettre au moment où la tête de mon
cheval y passe pour me permettre de
faire ma figure à l'endroit donné et pas
trop tôt ou trop tard puisque une figure
pas faite au bon endroit c'est
sanctionné donc du coup ça veut dire que
vous avez en tête parfaitement le
parcours et le trajet qu'il faut faire
c'est ça oui la là ce qu'on appelle la
reprise c'està-dire c'est l'enchaînement
des figures en fait on a on a des
imposés qu'on fait tous dans le même
ordre au même endroit les figures le le
parcours est le même pour tout le monde
et ensuite on a une reprise qu'on
appelle libre donc on est un petit peu
assimilé au patineur dans le sens où on
a des imposés à caler dans l'ordre qu'on
veut où on veut sur une musique qu'on
choisit et qu'on essaie d'adapter aux
allures du cheval pour que ce soit le
plus harmonieux possible là les Jeux
paralympiques sont terminés les jeux de
Londes sont terminé vous pensez déjà à
la suite pour ce qui me
concerne je pense avant tout au je je
mondiaux de 2014 puisque le paraquestre
est une discipline qui a été intégrée au
niveau de la Fédération Équestre
Internationale et donc depuis 2010 on a
la chance de faire nos championnats du
monde en même temps que SEP autres
disciplines chez les valides et il
s'avère qu'en 2014 les jeux mon Dieu
vont être vont vont avoir lieu en France
à Camp donc pour moi c'est le prochain
objectif et vous me disiez aussi que
vous allez essayer peut-être de de
participer au championnat de France
valide c'est ça bah parallèlement au
Para moi je tourne aussi sur le circuit
valide et là j'ai encore une compétition
à faire pour finir de me qualifier pour
éventuellement aller participer au
championnat de France qui vont se
dérouler début novembre à sa mur et
comment ça se passe justement avec les
valides lorsque vous arrivez sur une
compétition comme celle-ci je suis comme
un autre il y a pas de différence ouais
il y a pas de différence entre les entre
les athlètes de de haut niveau en ce qui
vous concerne Florence pour vous vous
préparez aussi 2016 ou prochaine
compétition ouais c'est c'est le projet
en effet je suis rentré de Londres avec
l'envie de de continuer et de et de
repartir sur 4 ans en sachant qu'il faut
que je réorganise des
choses sportivement et
professionnellement chose don tout à
l'heure qu'on a pas précisé Florence a
déjà participé aux Olympiades mais
exactement vous êtes une jeune pongiste
si je puis dire c'estàdire qu'avant vous
étiez inscrite en athlétisme oui tout à
fait j'ai fait trois Olympiades en
athlétisme donc j'ai pratiqué cette
discipline pendant 16 ans et le tennis
de table est une reconversion donc que
je pratique depuis depuis 12 ans
maintenant une belle reconversion donc
alors oui merci à toutes les deux d'être
venu et félicitations pour ces
différentes participations merci Anthony
on vous retrouvera lundi pour un point
complet sur le sport du weekend dans la
page sport traditionnelle du 78